[Music]
on this Wednesday night demonstrations
disruptions and no resolutions in sight
pipeline protestors confront the Deputy
Prime Minister the calls / calm that's
unacceptable and the economic
consequences Plus why this issue is so
complicated for First Nations ship no
longer shunned welcome news for everyone
on a quarantined cruise mysterious
messages from space are we really alone
out there and one on one with Canada's
number one soccer star I have never
played soccer just for the goals
Christine Sinclair on her success and
her goal to advance the game every
chance that a guy gets though on a girl
to get it
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
disagreement over a natural gas pipeline
in northern BC is a gain disrupting
trade and travel in this country a key
rail line in southern Ontario is still
blocked by people showing solidarity for
opponents of the coastal gasoline
pipeline that crosses traditional
territory of the wood so it in people
and today a new blockade went up on the
CN Rail line just west of Winnipeg Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau travelling in
West Africa said today protesters must
obey the law we recognize the important
Democratic right and we will always
defend it a peaceful protest this is an
important part of our democracy in
Canada but we're also a country of the
rule of law we need to make sure those
laws are respected but police have not
moved in to remove the protesters
hundreds of freight trains in via rail
passenger trains are sitting idle for a
seventh day and this happened to Deputy
Prime Minister Chrystia Freeland today
she was blocked from entering Halifax
City Hall by self-described
land defenders who refused to make room
for her she did eventually manage to
slip inside and then had this to say it
is very important for all people in
Canada including government officials to
be able to go there
legitimate business even as other
Canadians are expressing their right to
peaceful protests how to resolve this
remains the question though indigenous
rights can be a political minefield and
so is the complex issue of hereditary
leadership within though with so it in
people and who has the authority to say
yes or no to a pipeline like look at or
has our top story tonight for nearly a
week one of Canada's busiest rail
corridors has been ground to a halt by
the time de Naga Mohawk blockade its in
support of the wets Odin nation
protesting the proposed coastal gas link
pipeline in northern BC there's now a
second camp a little further down the
rail line the only way to get Canada to
stop for a second and to say hey what
are we doing is to stop there money
right politicians have taken notice and
say the economic impact is real do we
have a report that there's been in
excess of 100 trains that have been held
back if you will well I can only surmise
that a number of those trains have
energy on them saskatchewan energy i can
only surmise that a number of those
trains will have a Saskatchewan potash
on them the Federal Transport Minister
is calling on protesters to respect
court injunctions that were supposed to
end the demonstrations so I can't accept
more mail but this video posted of what
Mohawks did to a previous injunction
might foreshadow their response to any
others there's a court injunction the
RCMP has not moved in yet and the
Finance Minister is appealing to the
protesters on behalf of all Canadians we
think about the people impact
I mean people can't get to the places
they want to go if they're impeded to
use the rail system and of course we
always need to remember that a lot of
our food in our country goes by rail my
advice to the crown would be to
establish a process with what Sultan
people's the National chief of the
Assembly of First Nations is imploring
the crown to start a dialogue parry
bellegarde says the government must sit
down with both the wet Soudan ban
councils who support the pipeline
project and the hereditary Chiefs who
oppose it get into the big house and
feast we have our own processes to
resolve disputes go back to that
you ceremony use our elders use our
traditions to bring about a resolve into
this issue still there are many in the
community who want the pipeline and say
the hereditary Chiefs and the protesters
don't speak for everyone we need jobs
like if you go into one place where
where you're isolated and everything you
know the band can only you know get so
much job take worries that he and many
others who support the pipeline won't be
heard because of the protests across the
country
Michael cooter global news Ottawa who
speaks for the with so it and people and
who has authority over the twenty two
thousand square kilometers of land in
northern BC is not straightforward
there's confusion and misunderstanding
and there's word a call has gone out for
a meeting of with so itand leaders to
resolve it the divide is between some
hereditary chiefs who are organized by
clan and anchored in cultural traditions
and band councils created under the
Indian Act who are elected to represent
the people on reserves some hereditary
Chiefs oppose the pipeline and believe
they have authority over the territory
which has never been seated and is not
subject to a treaty but all twenty
elected band councils along the route
including five elected with so and band
councils representing about twenty eight
hundred people support the pipeline and
have signed benefit agreements with
coastal gas leak both prime minister
justin trudeau NB c-- premier John
Horgan backed the terminal and the
pipeline there's a misunderstanding
broadly of what hereditary leadership is
and we're working hard to figure that
out the vast majority of people in that
territory want to see progress and and I
believe that they have to figure that
out if completed the coastal gasoline
pipeline would supply natural gas to LNG
Canada which is building an eighteen
billion dollar terminal in Kitimat BC it
would export liquefied natural gas to
Asia the future of another big resource
project this one in Alberta is hanging
in the balance the tech frontier oil
sands proposal has taken nine years to
go through the federal approval process
fourteen indigenous groups have signed
benefit agreements with the company now
on the eve of the deadline for a federal
decision one indigenous group wants it
delayed Heather Eurex West
explains why the Athabasca chippewa
first nation has fought against oil
sands development for years opposing
project after project in the region but
in the fall of 2018 after months of
negotiations it signed a conditional
benefits agreement with tech if we were
going to lose this one well we better
make an agreement to put stipulations in
place that's going to protect the
environment but the nation didn't just
want assurances from the resource
company its support was also contingent
on environmental protection work by both
the federal and provincial governments
the nation says Alberta hasn't held up
its side of the bargain we agreed to
this development we give our approval
100% and still the Alberta government
reneged on living up to the commitments
chief Adams still wants Ottawa to
approve the project but he says that
approval needs to come with conditions
that Alberta find a community-based
monitoring program and do more to
protect caribou habitat from our
perspective a delay on this project
would be the same as rejecting it we
have overcome every environment issue
that has been put in front of us and
we'll continue to work with all 14 First
Nation communities to address their
concerns in an ongoing way the province
says it's met with chief Adam a dozen
times since January and is working to
address the nation's concerns although
the provincial Environment Minister says
he suspects the pushback is more about
money
still this political analyst believes by
coming forward the First Nation has made
it difficult for the federal government
to approve the project outright they
would have to be either upon the
decision or they do accept it but based
on a set of fairly rigorous conditions
cabinets final decision on the proposal
is due at the end of the month Heather
your ex west global news Calgary the new
boss of BP one of the world's biggest
oil and gas companies says it's time to
reinvent itself
Bernard Looney wants VP to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions to Net Zero by
2050 or sooner he says BP will cut
carbon content by 50% by 2050 by selling
products that are not fossil fuels it
says it will install methane measurement
equipment at all its processing sites by
2023 so it can cut leakage carbon
dioxide
and methane both contribute to global
warming the new CEO says we all want
energy that is reliable and affordable
but that is no longer enough it must
also be cleaner it will require nothing
short of reimagining energy as we know
it
Looney says more details on how BP
intends to do it will come in September
there are reports from China tonight the
number of confirmed cases of Kovan 19
and the number of deaths has jumped
dramatically overnight though it's not
exactly clear why according to Chinese
media there are now more than 60,000
cases most of them in China that's a
jump of 15,000 nearly 10 times the
increase reported yesterday more than
1300 people are now confirmed to have
died these new numbers are contradicting
what the World Health Organization said
earlier about the numbers slowly
dropping that must be interpreted with
extreme caution this outbreak could
still go in any direction in China just
over 2,000 new cases were reported today
that's the lowest number of daily new
cases in two weeks
overall the World Health Organization
says there are now more than 45,000
confirmed cases most in China and more
than 1,100 people have died there is
some good news tonight for thousands of
cruise ship passengers waiting and
wondering when they can get back on land
after being denied entry by multiple
countries the MS Wester dam says it has
finally found somewhere to dock crystal
gyum ancing explains after being
rejected by five countries cheers for
Cambodia Holland America Line posting a
message expressing gratitude to
authorities in that country
no one is ill on board unlike the
diamond princess it really is an
exhausting day here sounds crazy when
there's nothing to do passengers on that
ship are under quarantine until the 19th
the diamond princess docked in Yokohama
has the most concentrated number of
kovat 19 cases outside of China we must
continue to
tried to stop the virus while preparing
countries for the arrival of requires
London recorded its first case the same
day more than 80 people were told
they're being released from isolation
the British nationals who were flown
back from Wuhan
will go home Thursday children believe
in Beijing a government spokesperson
said right now the epidemic situation is
still grim but with a series of strong
measures we have also seen some positive
changes the World Health Organization
says the situation in China appears to
be stabilizing but the fight isn't over
hammer it hammer this virus and prevent
it from being a serious problem or a
crisis in the rest of the world as the
fight against kovat 19 continues the
director-general called for calm and
solidarity crystal the Manson Global
News London
journalists politicians and readers
across the country are paying tribute to
writer Christie Blatchford who died
today I think what distinguishes this
case is that watchbirds career spanned
five decades as a columnist and reporter
and author of books she worked at for
major daily newspapers and made
appearances on global national she's
remembered as a fearless tenacious
reporter with searing wit and a passion
for human stories she was diagnosed with
lung cancer in November Blatchford was
68 years old scientists have a new
mystery on their hands tonight
coming up with strange sounds coming
from far and away
Canadian Prime Minister's are sometimes
put in a delicate diplomatic situation
when they travel abroad they're under
pressure to speak up for Canadian values
the host country doesn't necessarily
support david aiken explains what
happened to Prime Minister Trudeau
during a visit to the West African
country of Senegal these boys and girls
are becoming better basketball players
with some Canadian help but Justin
Trudeau thinks the basketball help will
make them better citizens we know that
the impact that we can have as a society
by empowering our young people goes far
beyond like Prime Minister's before him
Trudeau's overseas visits aim at
building people-to-people relationships
and on this trip that included Trudeau
learning about Africa's past Trudeau
visited gorae Island
that's a unesco world heritage site that
describes the experience of slavery
between the 15th and 19th century more
than 15 million people mostly from West
Africa were sold into slavery most were
sent to the Americas including Canada we
must remember the horrors and the
tragedies of the past
and reflect on their impact today and
into the future
many departed from gory islands slave
market onto a waiting ship through what
is known as the door of no return
Trudeau and Senegal President Macky Sall
talked about trade and security but a
Canadian Prime Minister is often pushed
to tie exports of lumber and grain to
exports of Canadian values here in
Senegal for example it is illegal to be
lesbian gay trans or queer while rape
was just criminalized last month but
Trudeau prefers not to lecture Senegal
is a country that has succeeded
tremendously instead Canada's method is
to show people here what life is like
back home and that's going to happen
through a year-long exchange program of
sports culture education it's what the
leaders are calling the year of Senegal
in Canada Donna all right David akin in
Senegal tonight thanks still ahead a new
pattern discovered in space deepens a
sonic mystery
[Music]
there's a lot of excitement around some
mysterious radio signals coming from
deep space Canadian scientists have
noticed a pattern in the bursts they
come from a single source half a billion
light-years from Earth
it's a scientific first and as Eric
Sorenson reports it has stargazers
trying to figure out who or what is
sending them fast radio bursts were only
first detected 13 years ago from immense
explosions millions of light-years away
the signals raced through the galaxies
in the nebula stretching as they go
finally spotted on earth one radio burst
wavelength light was converted to sound
thanks to a powerful new Canadian
telescope called chyme near Penticton BC
scientists have determined that radio
bursts can repeat watching from York
University
Paul Delaney the repeating part of it is
what is really exciting because now we
stand a chance of figuring out what
these things are
and the latest stunning discovery a
rhythmic pattern to see fast radio
bursts repeat is one thing to see them
arrive in rhythm is something else again
the signals have now been detected over
four days and then silence for 12 days
again and here's that sound over and
over for four days and then quiet again
for 12 and this cycle is repeating every
sixteen point three days like clockwork
could it be a message from millions of
light-years away just the idea of
intelligence elsewhere in the universe
has set the Twitterverse all atwitter
the notion of life communicating from
other galaxies makes some people nervous
one tweeted the truth is out there
others are curious maybe they're trying
to contact us or just plain eager please
tell me it's aliens and radio signals
with a beat who knows maybe they've got
rhythm - so can we imagine that it's
likely that this signal we're picking up
was sent by thinking beings what does
our expert Paul Delaney have to say it
is unlikely that this signal that we're
picking up was sent by thinking beings
oh the lady says a more likely scenario
is a binary star system with a signal
coming from one star that is lost
temporarily when it orbits behind the
other I'm not reaching out to ETA at
this point in time there is much more
likely to be an Astrophysical
explanation but could it be a message
from far away you can't rule it out I
mean I cannot say categorically well
then we can keep guessing and as they've
said since the discovery of radio
signals stay tuned Erik Sorensen Global
News Toronto
max I scored a sit-down with Sports
superstar Christine Sinclair who tells
me about her next goal it's only
February and it's already been a banner
year for Christine Sinclair she set an
astonishing record she scored the most
goals in international soccer 185 no
woman or man has scored more she's
played professionally for 20 years now
and is going to her fourth Olympics
Canada's women's soccer team is
qualified for Tokyo 2020 for now
Sinclair is back home and British
Columbia meeting fans and being
celebrated for her achievements
I met Sinclair in Vancouver and she's
the consummate Canadian understated
modest but with steely resolve to win I
started by asking her about what it
feels like to be an international sports
superstar I think it's a testament to
like the longevity of my career and I've
been able to adapt with the game but
honestly just most excited that we're
going to another Olympics and getting a
shot at the podium yeah yeah is that
what you always have your eye on is the
next thing rather than I mean I know you
do
you were proud and it showed when you
got that goal and then set the record
but it's not like you're over-the-top
excited about it right because you're
always looking ahead yeah you know I
have never played soccer just for the
Gulf you know I always say I chose a
team sport for a reason just trying to
achieve something together you know when
people watch you play they try to figure
out what's going on in your head what do
you call that scores instinct you have
to be at the front of the net at the
right time I'm not sure I think like I
get asked that quite a bit I I honestly
think I was born with it I understand
the game I think I can read it pretty
well on the pitch and then in front of
goal right yeah I get asked what goes on
in your mind Vince absolutely nothing
it's just
calm and most times and
yeah I think compost so you started when
you're four you've been at this
international level for what 20 years
yeah is there ever a time when you score
a goal that there's less sparkle to it
less excitement less of course I mean
because I we playing I mean the women's
game isn't quite where the men's game is
yet and so we've played in some games
and some stadiums where there's like
five people there and in the middle of
nowhere
is it's not the same as scoring in front
of like 50,000 Rams well let me ask you
about the women's game how much has it
changed in the 20 years that you've been
in it night and day you know when I
first joined the national team no one
don't cared there weren't many
opportunities for for female soccer
players around the world and now you
have players completely skipping
University to go play pro and then just
at the international stage I mean think
you saw it at last last year's World Cup
it's it's just growing it's it's and
this is just the start and you've been a
key part of that right no I've just
played you've just played but you are
you know what you are to so many young
women and and guys too and boys play
right you are like the crown jewels haha
that was pretty cool to see like you're
playing at home and there's like young
boys wearing your Jersey to be able to
see young the youngsters like you know
the dream of representing their country
going to Olympics going to World Cups I
mean that's how it started for me what's
missing from the women's game what would
you like to see where would you like to
see it go from here
mmm
we call the mend every chance that a guy
gets I want a girl to get we're moving
in the right direction but like at a
very slow pace and are you one of these
people who doesn't want to jinx it by
saying what your goal is in Tokyo or do
you have a goal in life
we're going with podium this time yeah
yeah so and we're sick of France so
people can take what they want from that
I'm taking it she's going for gold that
is global national for this Wednesday
I'm donor Friesen tonight's here Canada
is Vancouver where the Olympic Cauldron
was relit to mark 10 years since the
city hosted the 2010 Olympic Games
thanks for watching Robyn Gill we'll be
here at the anchor desk over the next
few days and I'll see you here again
next week bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]